nurse 30-1 you hit it you called it on
the show
i'm happy my bank account's happening
i'm giving away hoodies all show you're
getting a hoodie for that you get a
hoodie
all three of you get hoodies mikey how
many hoodies you giving out today like
45
i'm not counting who knows it's time
we're all going in together
we have somebody here who likes to face
the group chat you guys are the absolute
worst
put some bleeping respect on my name why
are you even in this group chat you're
not even betting and not even telling me
i'm wrong you have no
original takes get him out again i don't
want you in here get out of the group
chat goodbye
[Music]
you just joined the br betting group
chat
we've got locks we've got hoodies to
give away and we've got a game seven
especially weshy coming up for you today
yeah oh yeah i am vern alongside kelly
in vegas
mikey locks greg ivory and cabbie
richards we're gonna be giving away
hoodies all show
so keep firing off your takes in the
comments and we are grateful the nba is
back and to be here talking to you
about our favorite bet but the boycott
happened for a reason
and cabbie has some words for us today
thank you vern
we salute the nba and wnba players for
continuing to use their platforms
to inspire substantive change in their
local markets
with government officials we salute you
for
influencing your board of governors to
stay committed to social initiatives
and to inspire millions to continue
having dialogue about the inequities in
society so we salute you it's got to be
hard
to be fully focused on basketball with
all these other things going on
but with some positive changes it's um
it's good to be able to watch the
playoffs finish out so
thank you very much ladies and gents of
the nba and wnba
well said cabbie thank you cub
appreciate that
and let's get into it this is our game
seven special
at the end of this show we're gonna let
you decide what we are hammering
as a family in the jazz nugs match up
tonight
it's jamal murray it's donovan mitchell
both have dropped 50 plus
and we want to know which of them you
think is going to post another
huge number tonight look at that we got
a little boosty boost down at the bottom
from our friends and fanduel
love that whatever you decide we're
gonna hammer together
so drop your takes in the comments
through the show
and now let's talk about one of the
group chat's new favorite bets
the same game parlay mikey what are you
feeling for we're doing it vernon doing
it i just
i need to get rich by the way i'm seeing
a lot of what to do in the comments just
fire off hot takes make fun of vern
give the rest of us a compliment i am
giving way too many hoodies away i'm
gonna get yelled at for it
but vern the same game parlay my
goodness every time i check
we are betting on ig give them
everybody's getting money
18k this is messy 17k everybody hey
3 500 all on the same game
i want this i need this we need this job
as a family greg
kelly vern it is our time to get rich
let's get a yacht or some other great
straight
mikey you and there's a reason you
haven't posted any of those because you
were bad at betting
but let's cook one up for us together as
a family we're about to be a
family and you're going to give me that
come on man let's go five
leg each of us picks a leg i'm going
first i like the jokic
under two and a half three pointers made
tonight
game's gonna tighten up in the playoffs
i feel like he's going low
can i get my vern impression while i get
mine where he's like trying to be all
smart
talking cliche it's gonna be tight in
the playoffs i think it's really gonna
like get out of here with that no i'm
taking joe angle dirt emoji to heart
sharp emoji it's a sharp emoji for me
because i'm a shark and the sharps
right now aka me are taking joe ingles
over one and a half three-pointers the
guy is going to be firing threes he
usually gets up there around six seven
attempts he hasn't been hot lately now
i'm acting like burton just take it i
don't know
yeah i'm gonna say i'm sick analysis
right there uh mikey locks with the with
the utah jazz they acquired
mike conley jr last summer from the
memphis grizzlies because of his play
making and because of his veteran
leadership
i'm taking the over five and a half
assists in game seven
versus the nuggets let's build this
let's get rich guys i like that
i like that i went back and forth on a
lot a lot of these
today and and you guys know this isn't
my strong suit
so i'm going to ask mikey what he likes
mike you like my pitch just i want i
need the i need the verification
i like your pick okay thank you give me
give me a pick on rudy gobert over under
15 and a half points
thank you kelly we're kind of vibing as
a group now this is good
juju as we go hit the same game parlay i
think yeah take gobert over i think
i i think people are going to be scoring
put me down for the ender
let's go after all that yes
kelly's smart that's a good tank thank
that's how she do you mikey that's how
she do you that's crazy but
i'm gonna give you guys a lock here my
guy michael porter jr is sitting at
11 and a half points that's low
he needs to have a big game if denver
wants to win
this series the jazz half cooled him off
a little bit
but i'm hammering the over i see him
having a big game
i see him showing up so give me the mpj
over let's go wow that is black book it
now
all right okay it is official this is
our
five leg parlay right here
on the screen look at those odds we get
a huge multiple there
mikey i hope people are riding with us
what are they saying in the comments
ifcbob88 says take this pick for some
random ass reason
i'm pretty sure he was hating on me but
i'm gonna for for me i'm gonna spin zone
that he was hitting on you
so ifc bob you get a hoodie for that
kelly not being nice
you're right joanne she is not being
nice a leon three our time to get rich
it is our time together to buy yachts
i'm giving you a hoodie for that
thank you for the positivity let's have
party vibes gbs all right if you're
fantasizing
if you're if you're visualizing the
yacht we all know the best part of the
parlay
is thinking about what we're gonna spend
the money on so mikey
what are you seeing what are you feeling
vern this is a good question
i mean this will hit so it's a good idea
for all of us to start thinking to start
scheming
what are we buying i don't know uh for
me though i got to get back to neutral
you know i had kind of a tough run since
i
cut the mustache off been in a dark time
i'm gonna get back to neutral with this
parlay
and then after that we're gonna hit
another parlay then we buy the yacht
then we get vibey mikey you should go
back to buying the trying to buy those
diamond earrings for your wife or
oh i told you that yeah yeah
are coming out here on the uh i spent
money that i thought i had
i i don't know i don't like this guys
like we shouldn't be counting our
chickens before they hatch like it's
just
it just we shouldn't be stacking our
what do you mean we shouldn't be
counting our chick that's exactly what
we should be doing
it will hatch we're going to count the
chickens you sound like my grandma
i believe in the pumpkin but it look it
okay it would be nice
i saw these on br kicks last week it
would be nice to get a new pair of kobe
5s the pro churros
the big stages but i want to wait till
the stacks come in before i start
you know uh shopping around to get me
those those fives
those fives i i love those fives but i'm
not spending my money on that
uh pre covet my answer probably would be
different uh
probably be at dre's probably get
daylight lit
turned up or something but uh since
since we're in the middle of covet and
um i want you guys to really listen to
me and
and and really vibe with me here because
this means a lot to me hennessy
what that's what i'm putting my money on
anything's possible
yes sir twenty-five percent lost
anything
i love that greg anything is possible
when you're under the influence of
hennessy
and uh i think i started something mikey
i think i got a little uh
a little a little uh phrase for the
tinnies the henny and the tinnies
and tinnies let's go right now i love
this
this is by the in honor of those vibes
i'm going to be a good friend
mikey locks needs help mikey locks is
unwell
he's my friend and i can see this and so
i will be fronting him
in order to save him so mikey you will
pay me back
but when this hits i got you so i do owe
you 200 bucks from the virtual ponies we
killed a cold streak last night
or you're saying that even right
officially on the group chat show in
front of everyone
that is awesome literally the opposite
of whatever that's what i heard though
i heard
[Laughter]
you guys are all a disaster uh greg you
can buy a bottle hit a seat just not at
the club with your winnings okay like
kathy wants to buy a thousand dollar
pair of shoes mikey needs to buy three
thousand dollar earrings so his wife
doesn't leave him
i don't know why you'd ever loan your
money to mikey locks but that's cool
no the correct answer here is guys this
is like the stock market this is an
investment you roll your money back in
your bankroll sure you can take a small
portion treat yourself who doesn't want
to treat themselves what do you put it
back in your bank roll
so you can continue to bet she's being
our mom again what is bankroll
management i still have no idea what it
means that's the worst answer i've ever
heard we're not going to hit a parlay
and then not go crazy and buy some henny
and some new kobe's come on kelly
mikey what what are the people saying in
the comments are they with us are they
with kelly
they're uh they are with us first of all
hudson alas says i'm spending my money
on a hoodie but i can get a free one if
someone gives it to me
don't spend your money on the hoodie go
buy some honey i will give you a hoodie
right now
send us a go uh and never go wrong with
some henny j peters 25
yes sir um yeah i think
people are are already realizing that
we're going to what cabbies count our
chickens as they hatch i don't know
they're saying
but we're getting rich look i'm just
saving you there
i need to address this we got to talk
about the rockets thunder game last
night amazing
the haters are saying i had a meltdown
on twitter i'm from
houston i may you did have a meltdown no
i did not people
it's okay vern we've all been there i
had a meltdown after the illinois
michigan state game last year i don't
know if i've even still recovered
meltdown and you didn't even come again
what did i do that was a meltdown
say one two words saying some of the
worst takes i've ever had say one say
one specifically it was truly awful
say one specifically oh you're you don't
know
yes but i like chris paul and i was just
saying that if he was healthy a few
years ago the rockets would have beaten
the warriors
that's all chris hall was great last
night i had a meltdown online
it's okay i was just teasing my friends
i was taking that pain
and trolling with it i was the venus
they were the fly i'm the fly trap
okay what does that mean right that's
the dumbest thing that's that is the
dumbest thing i've ever heard no
there's a flower where did you get that
i am the bright light and you were
buzzing into me i told you that was a
good idea to say
yeah that's bad like how are you betting
at game seven
the rockets are gonna win okay not only
because i
am a rockets fan russ westbrook is
he's been great for the last two months
i'm not gonna let one
quarter change the way i vote i
recommend or bet
do you think russ is 100 that's the
question you have to have i think they
put him back in there too early i i
that's my only thing besides this awful
pass out of bounds with 12 seconds left
you guys could have went to overtime to
take it i was very happy i had okc plus
5 i didn't sprinkle on the money line
don't ask me why so this time i am
sprinkling on the money line
i'm gonna take okc plus the points and
the money line greg agrees with me i
like it
yes yes i'm oh wait that's not great
that's great i'm glad i'm
i'm the other way yeah but i'm loving
that
i honestly think i mean last week i was
on
okc telling you guys about how they were
this
is their year uh to beat houston so uh
i'm rocking with you
who's with me is anyone with me on the
rocket i'm with you i'm with you vern i
love the narrative of like the revenge
series chris paul and russell westbrook
you know against their former teams russ
is not going to have a quarter like that
ever again
yes as kelly mentioned he's battling
like a a right quad injury
and he's going to be on a minutes
restriction in game seven but you have
the beard you have
robert covington and you have houston is
playing defense
they're forcing isolation ball i know
it's crazy to say houston plays defense
but the rockets are playing defense and
they're going to win in game seven
and continue on in the western
conference playoffs
vern i will side with you if you can
just like what is the fly trap thing i
still have no idea what the analogy is
something says that the fly trap analogy
was dangerously landing which i don't
think it was landing
give that person a hoodie give that
person a hoodie no i'm not here no
hoodies for that i'm winning
i will ride with you can you offline it
can we circle back offline on what you
were actually talking i will explain
it where are you betting at game seven
locks
thank you rockets sure whatever next
okay
the eastern conference playoffs are set
we've got a little upset action
brewing who are we taking in the east
are you guys changing your picks at all
you must you must be talking about like
an upset with the heat
over the bucks because you can't be
mentioning
you can't be referencing the defending
nba champion toronto raptors
because the defending nba champion
toronto raptors will repeat they will
they will get out of the east look at
that value plus 440
on fanduel it was just a blip it's only
one game
pascal ciacom is going to find his game
again and fred van vleet and his
adorable kids are in the bubble it's
going to inspire daddy to have another
boost
and he's not going to be terrible in
game one again fred van vliet's going to
come back
raptors baby plus 440.
that's that's the team i like that value
cab i'll i'll rock with you there
everyone knows we don't lose bets when
we bet together too
uh cpt jake sparrow cpt that means
captain first can you confirm that there
it is yes
okay he says make me hoodie mellow i'll
make you captain jack sparrow
hoodie i don't know what i'm talking
about you get a hoodie though i am awful
riding with the raptors that's it that
was awful wasn't it
was it really bad okay yeah cool that
was really bad that was just
just stop i got it okay listen
kelly today can we get our vibes back
everybody was overreacting to game one
right now the raptors are plus 150 to
win that series
the bucks are minus 184 to win that
series those numbers have moved a ton
because of one
game i still pick the raptors and bucks
to move on i still have that and i
really like the value
at raptors plus 440 they're gonna get
the win today and they'll be right back
in that series
they are gonna get the win today i did
bet toronto today
but i'm still going with the team i said
weeks ago had a ton of value in the
easter conference final
jimmy butler in the miami heat sorry
giannis
i do love you you are the greek god but
you are only one man
and you cannot carry this buck's team
very much further i think miami wins
that series
goes on to play cabbies toronto raptors
in the eastern conference finals
but i gotta take miami they'll be a
sizable underdog to toronto i think it's
gonna be a great series
now kelly i don't dislike your bet i
actually
kind of like it but i see a better bet
i'm rocking with the celtics they have
really been yelling
in the what
i'm rocking with the celtics they have
really been gelling in the playoffs
they're undefeated jayson tatum's been
balling
i mean he's turning into a superstar
jalen is brown he's been knocking down
the threes playing defense
mark is smart he's been doing the same
thing he's knocking down three's playing
defense
marcus smart's not gonna have 21 points
again and have like five corners
my dude cabbie cabbie wait because i
have to say something kimball walker
dribble dribble tween tween drive and
kick
that's what he does finds the open men
and they knock down the shots i'm riding
with the celtics i think this is their
year the warriors aren't in the playoffs
i think i thank you for your analysis
mikey you just went through like the
weirdest longish feel
about value and a bunch of other
meaningless stuff
the bucks are winning the east that's it
i'm not overthinking it
boom box plus 120. yeah it looks like
chocolate
eating reacting i will
talk mikey what are people people are
saying that jalen brown is better than
ciaco
having your thoughts that's that's
ridiculous the pascal
is averaging 24 points jaylen brown is
nice
he is nice i don't know if that's
ridiculous though cabbie
i mean pascal has grown up he's not he
was the second best player on a
championship team last
year guys let's not forget what happened
12 months ago
14 months ago he still has the dna jimmy
buckets relax
the business clown oh three two three
you get a hoodie for that i like jimmy
buckets right now
okay got me all fired up i'm gonna save
cabbie here
get out your olive garden gift cards it
is our family that when you're here your
family
that's that joke we asked you on social
what their combined score is gonna be
it's jamal murray it's donovan mitchell
we're asking you again now
what are we betting tonight on fanduel
who do you think is gonna go off again
for game seven
of jazz nuggets is it jamal murray is it
donovan mitchell
maybe both of them a little boosty boost
there at the bottom look at those
odds hello what does everyone think
i'm gonna let cabbie take the floor i
know we're on the same side here but he
is the president of the jamal murray fan
club
so cabbie tell the people why we like
the over
we are rocking with this 23 year old
superstar
jamal murray and the over 31.5 points in
his last three games he's averaging
64 from the field he's a point guard
he dropped a 50 piece then a 42 p then
another
50 piece he is built for moments like
this he's played in two game sevens in
his career
the last one against portland he didn't
fare so well so he's gotta make up for
that and jamal murray is inspired
listen i'm from canada jamal's from
canada and
vince carter inspired a nation of
basketball players
it is now jamal murray's turn to inspire
a nation of basketball players in canada
and he is ready for this moment 31 and a
half
points take the over in game seven let's
go
the most important question though is
rodney i like that throwing arrows
mikey i'm trying to ask about the odds
boost
geez uh i'm probably
i'm over 35 i'm plus 230. because it's
it's great value 35 points
is is reasonable because the guys who's
been electric
the past few three games so i'll
probably sprinkle on that plus 230 from
fanduel
you have sold me i'm on the murray over
that's it
kelly you with us we're sprinkling on
the odds booth as well
let's go what not so fast guys there
is a dog on the opposite side of the
court
that name his name is donovan mitchell
hold on kathy let me pull out my laptop
and
and and and gather some statistics
i can't talk but let me gather some
statistics there it is uh from his
recent games
he dropped 44 the other day he dropped
51 the other day
and then game one he dropped 57.
this guy has been on fire give me the
over
i'm taking it that's going to be so easy
uh let's go let's get rich off this
right here
let's get ready see that everybody's on
the over i was worried kelly might take
the under that's kind of what she does
she saves the group sometimes
she doesn't know what it is this is just
like the damian lillard thing where
the books just haven't adjusted yet and
my personal opinion
i think murray's gonna have a great game
i think mitchell's gonna have a great
game it's gonna be a
great game seven i do not think that the
under is a very smart bet here
mikey where what are you taking look
these boosties vern these boosties have
caught my
eye i think both guys are gonna go
absolutely off murray's getting boosted
to plus
230 to go over 35. spider yeah we know
20 to go over 40. i love both of those i
talked about it
spider and murray's over you take both
of them to hit the over which the
commenters love
oh and i love that parlay pays you plus
230 on fanduel i'm not sure i think i
want to go with this
i'm in mike i love that bet ah man count
again
mikey the comments are saying is that
our official pick so
yeah well i think it will be i don't
know there's a lot of comments i can't
really
hold on hold on hold on be honest hold
on g-money g-money document you should
probably
what's up okay ever to win the series
because
then the jazz will be the latest team to
blow a 3-1 lead
and then you know people won't fight
golden state warriors anymore
so you can pick him out pick him out
yeah kick him out
kick him out he has to go he has to go
the nicest guy on the show just got you
guys mikey
it sounds like we're taking the parlay
can you confirm that parlay is gold
neil var you get a hoodie for that i
agree with that
look everybody when we ask what is the
combined over under
uh excuse me what is the combined point
total for both murray and spider
people were dropping 81 89. i saw a
couple of hundreds in there everybody
loves the over
we love the overs we are parlaying them
both together at plus right
that is your family ride right i just
need the vibes can we get the vibes back
let's get cabbie back in here let's get
cabbie sorry sorry cabbie let me
we're gonna go with cabbie
i think it was incredible don't you dare
apologize i'm not
remember i'm just speaking
remember what we taught you here today
we are going to get over
feelings go cabbie i want one more dig
on greg
and the golden state warriors that was
so good kick her out
kick her out
we're getting rich on our game seven
five leg parlay
do not listen to kelly and put your
winnings in the bankroll and said buy
something nice for yourself
once we hit that parlay and we're going
to be hammering another parlay it's the
donovan mitchell
jamal murray point total over on fanduel
as a
family thank you guys for watching
leaving the chat
game seven baby nothing easy